thank you it's good to be back I was
here four years ago and you know in the
before times uh and it's nice to be back
again
I wanted to talk to you about
abstraction
today because uh abstraction turns out
to be probably the most important thing
uh to being a good developer
to understand when to use it what it's
for am I am I doing it right do I need
more of it and so on
and uh I thought it would start though
with some thank yous
I've been getting up on stages for about
20 years and in most of that time
speakers get up and they tell you that
they're going to spend an hour or an
hour and a half with you and share
wisdom with you
and it sounds like they thought it all
up by themselves it just came to them
one day when they were at their desk for
no good reason and a few years ago a
Conor Hoekstra and if you don't know
Connor I strongly recommend that you
seek him out
uh started doing talks where he said I
was watching this talk and I was reading
this blog and I was listening to this
podcast and I decided to put this piece
of this together with this piece of that
and that's what this talk is
and I realized that's how all talks
happen Okay uh we do something at work
we listen to something we watch
something we talk to a friend over
dinner and it turns into a talk
and Connor really started telling the
truth about that instead of implying
that we all just make all this stuff up
in our Ivory Towers alone
so in that spirit
last year guy Davidson wrote this book
he likes to say that we wrote this book
but that's not really true he wrote all
the words
um I helped him to choose which of the
30 core guidelines of which 30 of the
hundreds of core guidelines we would
talk about
and uh you know worked a little bit on
you know choosing examples or maybe this
paragraph should be before that
paragraph that kind of thing but he
really did all the work
and what we discovered we chose the
guidelines
to cover a variety not all the same
stuff but over and over and over again
they boiled down to
you should do this highly specific piece
of C plus plus syntax and the answer for
why was always because that's better
abstraction it was like we said it's
just abstraction all the way down
uh also Tony uh Canadian like me did a
talk at simplest plus now last year
which was allegedly about the solid
principles I'm kind of meh on the solid
principles these days for a variety of
reasons but that's okay because the talk
really wasn't about the solid principles
at all but it was about like designing
and architecting uh classes and
abstractions and I learned a lot from
that talk as well and I recommend you
seek out Talks by these three people uh
you won't be disappointed
here's the thing
we teach abstraction
we kind of lie
here are The Lies We Tell people
you you find your abstractions before
you write your code
you have to write them down in some kind
of a notation
I have books by people like Grady booch
that came with plastic templates in the
back to help you draw the little shapes
on paper the lozenges and clouds and
whatnot that represented the different
notations for uh for object orientation
and you need to understand
whatever domain it is you're writing it
so my undergraduate work is in chemical
engineering
so if I was going to model as I did
chemical reactors and refineries you
know you have to understand how a heat
exchanger works or how pump works that's
how you can write good code to model one
of those
if you're going to write something that
sells things to people and charges them
sales tax you need to understand the
rules of sales tax not just to write the
code but even to design it
so for example in some countries there
is just a sales tax rate period
in many countries some things are
taxable and some are not and in others
there are different rates for different
things
so designing and saying every object
will have a sales tax rate might not in
fact be the correct design in some
countries
and probably the biggest lie is that
once you've done that you're good
going forward if anything changes they
change the rules for sales tax or
whatever you'll just go to this one
place and you'll change it
sorry about my throat
now when I call these lies right they're
really just simplifications
my granddaughter is five she's learning
to read
we tell her this is the letter c it
makes a cuss sound see for Chloe
C for cat
we don't tell her about Pacific Ocean
there's the Seas uh in Pacific Ocean
each make a different sound
and in the same way like C is for Chloe
and C does make a k sound for cat but
you're not a fluent reader of English if
you pronounce all C's that way
there are other things going on for
abstraction
the truth is yeah you do design
and find some abstractions and you do
need a way to write it down when you
don't have code
and you do need domain knowledge to
discover them
but you're not done when you found those
you've just started
you're going to continue finding
abstractions
for as long as this software exists and
most importantly you find those
abstractions completely differently
then the way you find them when you're
designing then the only way we've ever
taught you to find them
so that's what I want to talk about in
this talk is finding missing
abstractions in working code
you don't need to understand how
chemical reactors work you don't need to
understand how to run a rental car
business
okay this is not about drawing on a deep
domain knowledge
and you don't update the diagrams
you don't have any non-code notation for
these missing abstractions
and you certainly don't check with the
business
Hey listen you know we've got orders we
talked a lot about what orders do I've
decided to be useful if I had an order
item class is that okay with you that is
not a phone call you're ever going to
have
these abstractions are in the code you
see that in the code that there's a
missing abstraction the code tells you
about it code screams at you about it to
be fair
and then you put them in the code
whatever's missing if there's a missing
class you make a class now the
abstraction's in the code
foreign most people if you were to say
hey who's that person who's coming to
speak to us this week what does she do
they'll say oh she's a trainer and
that's fair I do a lot of teaching I
have a lot of courses on pluralsight and
elsewhere I want people to write 21st
century C plus plus
and I put a fair amount of time and
effort into that because I don't want
people to be afraid of C plus plus
I mean like if you're not careful at
parties I'll start talking about that
that's one of my things you know let's
just okay if it's a C plus plus party
but it's less okay if it's like a
neighborhood barbecue
and when I'm not getting paid to teach
and train I'll come in as a consultant
and sometimes it's as much a Management
Consultant as it is a C plus plus
consultant projects are in big trouble
and especially when people own code they
can't maintain
then this happens more often than you
might think
the last person who understood this code
is gone
in some cases I mean gone
the number of phone calls I've had that
has started with telling me that they
had someone who understood the code but
he died
this is a real thing
please do not be that person
please do not please do not die and no
one else knows how your code works
that's not job security
and uh and I come in
these situations and I figure out how to
make code that they can understand
and how to make code that they can
maintain
sometimes I have to teach them C plus
plus so they can read their own code but
a lot of times I have to fix the code
and what I have to fix about it is
generally that it is missing
abstractions that's why they can't
understand it it doesn't make any sense
because it's missing abstractions
but it's important to know that the
things I'm going to tell you are not
just about going into Legacy code yes if
you go into 30 year old code which I've
had to do you will find lots and lots of
opportunities to make it better
but with what I'm going to show you
you will catch yourself doing them live
like literally you will press enter
and you will look at the screen and you
will realize that there is a missing
abstraction in your 30-second old code
and you will provide the missing
abstraction
maybe you'll just add a comment I really
should make this a function but maybe
you'll actually make it a function
either way it will be better so this is
not a technique for approaching old code
it's also a technique for watching what
you do right in the moment while you're
doing it
so I've said missing abstractions a
bunch of times I've said I'm going to
give you abstraction patterns most
people think they know what an
abstraction is
they'll say an abstraction is a class
no a class is an abstraction
but many many things are abstractions
that are not classes
anything with a name
the minute it can have a name it is an
abstraction
a variable
is an abstraction compared to a literal
a class a function a file
anything with a name is an abstraction
and when we're doing those abstraction
lies we tell you that you do this to
avoid repetition and to avoid
duplication and that's true that is one
of the reasons for writing an
abstraction
it's probably not the most important I
actually think the most important is the
name
but that usually comes along with it
so I live in Canada Canada we work in
metric but we also work in Imperial we
have to be bilingual in measurement
systems as well as a little bit in
languages
and imagine that I've got some code
a couple million lines of code
and all over the place it needs to
convert between Fahrenheit and Celsius
I could just plonk the formula in
everywhere I needed it certainly any
Canadian is oh you're subtracting 32. I
see what's happening here yeah we're
going to divide by 9 we're going to
multiply by 5. I know what's going on
that's Celsius in Fahrenheit
but there's a good chance that once in a
while you would mess it up you make a
typo you subtract 33 instead of 32 that
kind of thing you'd divide by 9 instead
of multiplying that kind of thing
so you make a little function right C to
F and another function F to C
you don't do that because like with
sales tax what if the rules for
converting Fahrenheit to Celsius change
I'll only have to change this one
function we all know they're never going
to change
but we're eliminating that repetition of
the same formula over and over again and
we're giving it a name so that if
somebody reads it who doesn't know why
we're subtracting 32 they can tell from
the name of the function
we're actually isolating
the part of the problem that converts
temperature units into a place of its
own where everyone else can ignore it
and isolation is a very important part
of abstraction
if you take all the stuff that's related
to sales tax and you put it in a place
with a big sales tax sign in front of it
then everybody else can just trust okay
that's the sales tax stuff I don't need
to understand about that I can focus on
what I came in here to change which is
that I want the total to be blue or what
have you
separating the problem out into
different spaces lets different people
work on different parts of it
this is just as valuable as avoiding
repetition so there's no need for
something to be repeated over and over
again for you to choose to put it in
abstraction
of course the very best abstractions are
the ones that you just use instead of
writing
so there's a class or a function in the
standard library that will give you what
you need or there's a third party
library right so I need to look things
up in a table I need to manipulate
strings I need to parse Jason I need to
parse command line options
that's all solved problems I shouldn't
be writing all of that and if I find a
not very good implementation of it I
should probably be ripping it out and
putting in a good one
the world is now full of examples of
people who discovered they were
accidentally writing stood rotate
that seems to be a very popular thing
for people to not notice they were
writing and uh
it's obviously a better plan to use the
standard function than your own
in the book we say abstraction localizes
and minimizes complexity so rather than
having all those minus 32 divide by 9
whatever smeared all over your Millions
lines of code they're all in one place
everything else gets simpler
but the trick that you're not expecting
is that often when you do that the
overall complexity disappears because
this formula for going back and forth
between Fahrenheit and Celsius or
kilograms and pounds or what have you
are not exactly complicated formulas
and yet by putting them in one place you
didn't just localize the complexity you
actually make it completely disappear
so when code is missing abstractions
It's Your Role to provide them
and I just telling you that's going to
make the code better why well because if
you have thousands of lines of code if
you have a class with 50 member
variables I'm not making any of this up
this is all real how is that different
from Global mutable state
like really it's not
so you provide the missing abstractions
you provide smaller things and you get
all the benefits that we've always said
you'll get from abstractions
the simplest thing to do I said an
abstraction is anything with a name if
you have a magic number anywhere in your
code make it some kind of a variable
could be just like some local thing
could be a member variable of a class if
the if the formula is in a member
function of that class
it can be const sure it's a constant be
const expert that's also fine I don't
really care how you spell it what I
really care about is that it gets a name
well but how am I going to know the name
here's this big long complicated formula
it's got a 23 and a 17 and a 48 knit
well chances are there's a comment right
before the formula that pretty much
always is that says you know 17 is how
many I don't know provinces there are in
the country or something and and that's
where that comes from
the name is almost always right there in
the code because someone else has read
this formula and said why do we divide
by 23 here
and rather than introduce an abstraction
someone's just added a comment
there's a joke about a consultant being
someone who will borrow your watch to
tell you what time it is
but it but you know if you're walking
around with a watch on going man I wish
I knew what time it was then you you
need a consultant who knows how to read
watches for you and I very much borrow
people's watches when I look in their
code read their comments and use that to
give a variable a better name
so give your constants a better name and
not zero and one like real constants but
don't reinvent the wheel
if you've got seven in your formula
don't just introduce a constant called
days per week
Go off into the Chrono header
and see if there's something to convert
between days and weeks for you already
something that is uh already written to
handle all the weird edge cases that
might appear
you want pi okay bring in the numbers
header and use stood numbers Pi or
square root of 2 or where the other
number with a name you want is probably
in that header that's more expressive to
other people than you're a super cool
arc 10 of -1 or whatever related formula
that you've come up with to calculate pi
by
we'll start with a really simple one
I see this sort of thing all the time in
Old code
you've got uh report I chose report
because pretty much every old system has
does reports used to print them now it
emails them whatever okay and and they
used to just have the report
and then they're like oh actually the
reports are going to be a little bit
different for some people than for
others so they add like a report type
a member verbal to the report class
which is fine
and uh they decide to use these these
macros for the report type names
they typically all start with a common
prefix because of course macros are not
uh in their namespaced in any way so RT
is going to be the name for all of these
ones and then having apparently just had
this well we used up two letters we
can't be going crazy we'll just use one
or two from now on so we have rtb RTC
rtbc and so on
and you know how many mistakes you can
make I mean this is three but that's
because we're on a slide like in life
there's a hundred and seven or maybe 700
there's just like so many
and and you need to copy and paste and
there are three different things you
need to change the name the numerical
value and the comment
ask me how often people successfully
change all three
but then you know you what order do you
put them in do you keep them in
numerical order do you keep them in
alphabetical order how do you know like
if I'm just going to add another one and
I want to give it the value 2006 has
anyone already used 2006 there's a
delightful series of bugs when when two
of these have the same numerical value
right because then your switches and
whatnot are going into the wrong switch
and you can't figure out why
there's a ton of mistakes waiting for
you here
just using a new
okay now the numbers will be assigned by
the compiler so they're going to be in
the right order and you can use all 26
letters of the alphabet should you
desire
now this is an old school unscoped Anum
which means that the names have to be
unique so I might still need to have
some kind of a prefix on them like RT
basic and so forth
I normally would prefer you using a new
class a scope denim but these are very
often in a switch
and you can't switch on a new class
without casting it back to an INT first
so for that particular case you might
want to stick with the old school enums
which case you might need to put
um
prefixes on them so that you can tell
them apart from the other kinds of
basics
I meet a lot of this kind of stuff
super common and the person who who died
you know would have been able to look
over this and go what what what what no
no no no you have one of these truths
and one of these forces flipped but all
the new people are like I I don't know
the difference between these calls at a
first glance do you notice that two of
these are true in each call
it's generally a bad idea to have
consecutive parameters of the same type
but it really wouldn't be better if
there was one INT in the middle of all
of this right it's the sheer number of
parameters that's starting to make it
horrible
and I find it especially frustrating if
let's say the default is false
I really just want to turn on two of the
seven options but I have to specify
those other five falses because you know
defaults can only be at the end
so I've done this many times and it
helps enormously with readability just
make a struct
and uh in this case I'm taking advantage
of default values I'm going to make them
all false so now I only need to set the
ones that are going to be true
and I change the function to take an
instance of this struct
it's just a struct there's no Getters
there's no Setters there's no
encapsulation
and the code is pretty mechanical to
change
people say well where'd you get those
names from well those will be the names
of the parameters inside the function
right because the reason this
nobody sits down in that we teach
abstraction lies pre-design stuff and
says we should totes have a function
that takes seven Bulls like that was
that was not done on purpose right it
didn't used to take anything
and then it needed one we need a special
case for Europe so we pass in this pool
of whether it's Europe or not and then
it needed another one the year-end
version is special okay so it adds
another one uh what if the notices were
already sent and we're just updating
again but we don't want to do the
notices again okay so they just keep
adding so generally they have pretty
good names
and you just take the names of the
parameters and make them the names of
the elements that the struct and then
you mechanically anywhere in the code
for this update function where it said
if Europe something or another
you go if opt dot Europe and the rest of
the code is unchanged it's pretty simple
to do
then calling it looks like this I'll set
up a an update options object set just
the things that I want to Mark as true
because the rest all default to false
and call update Europe problem is a
pretty crummy name it's really just
telling you which two flags I turned on
if this was a real example I could
probably give it a better name there's
probably a particular circumstance that
corresponds to its preliminary results
for Europe
it's easy to tell the difference between
this one where I'm setting two different
things to true
but it's not just about parameter lists
that are hard to remember like seven
Bulls in a row
sometimes people are very confidently
sure that they know what your parameters
mean and they're wrong
so the classic example of this genre is
draw rect think for a minute about what
these integers mean
probably half of you thought there was
X1 y1 X2 Y2 and probably half of you
thought it was X Y width height or maybe
height width right it could go many
different ways
the problem is a missing abstraction
if my draw rectangle takes two points
now you know what those mean
when you make these structs
they might not end up as structs
so I've got some function that takes
three strings in a float
and I decide no you know what that's
actually some kind of an abstraction
it's not going to be an employee
or a purchase order because those kinds
of abstractions got figured out
back during design but maybe it's an
employment contract maybe it's an order
item something like that
this function that takes a t whatever T
is maybe this should be a member
function of the T class
maybe it should and after inventing the
struct there's nothing wrong with
stopping and asking yourself that
this is this really a free function or
is it better served to be a member
function of the class you just invented
now you know structs can have member
functions you know that but most of us
once we add a member function to
something we start thinking about
canonical classes and we're like oh the
member variable should be private I need
gets I need sets I'm going to use
special member functions how many
Constructors do I need oh rule of three
rule of five so like don't rush off to
do that this code was working
right
when these were just local variables
everything was fine the reason we have
private member variables
protect invariance
some classes have invariants so if I
write a bank account class and I have a
transaction log and I have a balance
if you were to start at zero and add and
subtract every transaction in the
history of the account you should end up
with the same number as what is in the
balance that is the invariant of the
bank account class and this is why you
don't have a set balance method
you have deposit which increases the
balance and adds a transaction
you have withdrawal which decreases the
balance and adds a transaction and
guarantees that
outside of those member functions the
invariant always holds
it is possible the structure you're
inventing do hold secret invariance like
maybe for your points that um X and Y
have to be in the same quadrant in the
particular Universe you're working in in
which case you might want to actually
have set methods that would deal with
that
but it's more likely that there's no
invariant whatsoever which means you
don't need that kind of encapsulation
you don't need Getters and Setters you
don't need destructors you don't need
special member functions of any kind
it's okay for these to just be a thing
with a name don't run off and do design
it is a good idea to look around I
mentioned that this free function taking
a t might be a member function
of the new t-class it's also possible
there's some other local variables that
belong in that class and some other
functions that take this new type that
should be member functions of it that's
fine consider that possibility
I don't like out params
I think if you've heard me talk before
you're familiar with the fact that I
don't like outpreps
you want to return something return
something
it's a pretty simple rule oh but I need
to return three things
oh well we've only had that capability
you know for as long as we've had the
language so I can understand you might
not have learned that part yet right you
can return a struct you can return a
pair you can return a tuple
struct has a name and its pieces have a
name this is all a good thing
you can write your own struct with names
other people have written a couple of
Fairly handy things optional
so if what you need is a Boolean like
this worked or not and then a value
which is only usable if the Boolean is
true well that's what optional does for
you expected can I say stood expected
yet
I'm getting nods from the people who are
not qualified uh
I've been using expected for quite a
while cybrand has a great one but we do
now have can expect stood expected
uh which is two thingies and it knows
which of them is legit one's what you're
expecting to calculate some object or an
integer whatever and the other is an
error type
and so then if everything works you get
what you expect back in the value and if
it didn't work you get an error in the
error
that work's been done take advantage of
that don't roll your own thing where you
have a bunch of pointers and you return
a Bool and then depending on the Bool
you look at different ones of the
pointers
uh it's much more readable for everyone
if you use things that people can look
up on CPP reference that's one of the
things I like about optional and
expected that plus they have some nice
uh bull conversions that let you say if
results and it does what you think it
should do
foreign
the other thing I see
I don't have to understand the code not
to know anything about running nuclear
reactors just need to be able to pattern
match is this kind of thing
now the older the code the more likely
it is that people declare a bunch of
stuff at the beginning without
initializing it and they're all clumped
up together like this but you can also
spot it when they're spread out a little
further they just don't fit on slides as
well
they all start with the same three
letters
that I see all the time two three four
letters it's because they're all parts
of the same thing in this particular
case they're all parts of an employee
that is the employee first name the
employee last name the employee title
and the employee salary and if you do
nothing more than just gather them up
into a single struct
and then declare an instance of it I
mean then you consider mechanically put
a dot between the EMP and the first name
EMP in the last name you're good to go
often this does lead you off onto other
things but just seeing the names all
starting with the same letters it tells
you that these are in fact one thing and
you can take advantage of that and put
that information in the code
take a look at these declarations again
in real life they might be slightly more
spread out
without even looking at the variable
names
you you see something here right there's
two clumps there's two thingies
and when you look at them more closely
the first clump
start value and value number of points
average tolerance this is some kind of
statistical something involving values
and the second clump
that's a Latitude a longitude and
altitude
visible secure this about some sort of
physical location they're clearly very
different
without I don't need domain knowledge
though all I really need is that blank
line
I call this a load-bearing blank line
right it's very clearly demonstrating
these are two things
okay
you can create two classes or two
structs now to hold these thingies
but look a little closer
look at the first line of each clump
how long have we been told not to
declare two variables on the same line
with a comma
and then if there's a pointer involved
it confuses people there's no pointer
but we still generally are told don't do
this
but whoever wrote this code did this
maybe didn't even notice that they did
it
that's what I love about this sometimes
I talk to the person who wrote it
and I say you knew they were a thing
start valid envel latitude and longitude
you knew they were a single thing you
declared them on a single line and the
person says huh
I guess I did
right
you're you're sending messages to the
future but also to yourself right now
when you want to declare start valid end
Val on a single line like that it's
because that pairing is really one thing
listen to yourself make it one thing
now a big part of refactoring oh my
goodness the big functions I've walked
up to 100 lines of code please you are
like little baby uh I used to routinely
have phone calls where the person would
say so if you go to line
5896 in such a file you will see and
that would be like
in the middle of a case statement that
was itself hundreds of lines long which
was in a switch statement which was
thousands of lines long and the file was
10 or 15 000 lines
and yeah we had to do a lot of
refactoring
but but how do you do that
how do you know where in these thousands
of lines of code to grab this 106 lines
and make them a function
blank lines
load bearing blank lines
there's also comments right the number
of people who are like pick out all the
rush orders
process the orders
like whoa you're so close so close
your tool will do this for you do not
ever try to do this by hand
and you know the best part of any
refactoring tool is the undo button
okay so you select 107 lines maybe
separated by some convenient blank lines
say extract function
and your tool says sure it's going to
take 11 parameters four of which are out
params
undo that was not the correct
refactoring you want to absolutely
minimize
the information flow into and out of
this function you've just invented yes
you need to be able to give it a name
but ideally it would take one two three
parameters and would return a value
and depending on where you choose to
select the lines that's what's going to
grow that so when you see that it has
three out params take a look at what are
the variables that are in that block of
code that are still used afterwards and
figure out maybe if I should select less
lines at the top or less lines at the
bottom or something so that that doesn't
work that way
let me take a couple tries but again
without any knowledge of the domain what
is the grouping of these hundreds of
lines of code that minimizes the
parameters that are going into and out
of that new function
and then you'll need to name it
but once you see the parameters and the
return type that often will be all you
need to understand it oh I'm I'm adding
up all of the totals okay
now if I have a 5000 line file and every
100 ish lines of code becomes a function
I then have a function that is 50
function calls in a row
perhaps that itself could do with a
little compression
here's where you need some judgment
okay maybe you could turn it into five
ish functions Each of which calls 10 ish
functions
don't ever do this numerically or
mechanically
uh one of my first jobs programming I
was an undergraduate student and at the
University of Waterloo we do co-op so
we're put out into industry and do real
jobs and uh and I was working in
industry in Fortran
and the person there who was in charge
of us was to my mind very old and
experienced I mean she probably was 24
25 years old uh and she knew everything
and one of her rules was no function
could be more than 20 lines long
so if you wrote a 21 line function
we didn't know any better and it seems
that she didn't know any better the
first 20 lines would be called like calc
1. and the last line would be called
like calc 2 and then you just call calc
one followed by calc 2. please don't
ever do that
so when I say like five and ten I don't
mean any of these numbers precisely
but would it make sense to take your 50
function calls and Clump them up a bit
yes if you can give the clumps names if
that gives value if this nine function
calls are all about permission
and these 12 down here are all about I
don't know sending emails or something
then you can give them names then that's
a good thing to do
if it's just going to add confusion if
it's just going to add another level of
indirection then don't do it just give
me the 50 function calls I think it's
unlikely that none of them have any
commonality but
don't invent
abstraction that doesn't have a name
that doesn't have a purpose that doesn't
add clarity
remember we're trying to reduce
repetition we're trying to reduce
duplication we're also trying to isolate
parts of the problem
I saw this on Twitter recently
someone was complaining about comments
at the end of a long
series of nested things that ended with
closed braces so you said while
somewhere inside the wall there's an if
it's like a couple hundred lines in the
if then inside one maybe the if maybe
the else there's like a for Loop and it
gets to the point where somebody feels
the need to label the close braces this
is the end of the four this is the end
of the if this is the end of the while
and the original assertion on Twitter
was that they were pointless they were
just noise they should be deleted and my
statement was no no no no no
it's telling you it's too long and too
nested don't just delete them use them
because very often
when I used to do this I would just copy
the original if and put that in the
comment but kids these days are way more
hard working than that they paraphrase
the condition
they're telling you the name of the
function that you're going to use to put
inside where these braces were
okay
it's got a name we're processing each
outstanding item or this is what you do
when you're over limit fantastic
foreign
does the if go in the function or is it
if
function
that's going to be a judgment call on
your part a couple different ways to do
it here's a situation using reports as
an example again and I apologize for the
font size but I'll read it to you for
every R in reports and then there's a
closed brace way down at the bottom of
the screen
if
we'll call ours header needed r dot our
points to do header so imagine this
didn't used to say do header used to be
20 lines of code
then we do some little local
calculations about how many lines are
going to be in the report and then while
for each line
well again r dot points to new line was
maybe 100 lines of code and that's why
we needed to have comments on the closed
brace of that while then we have another
if about if you need a footer
so this is a simple way to do it keep
your ifs keep your walls keep all your
nesting but just take whatever was
between the braces and make it a
function
because of the scoping of braces the
chances are you'll have really limited
parameter action when you pick these out
into functions these are member
functions they're only working with
member variables is fine
so this isn't wrong
but you might prefer
to do this
so what this says is you know what I
don't know who this code is that's
looping through all the reports
but why does it need to know whether a
report needs a header or not
why is that the business of this calling
code we think about encapsulation and
abstraction and keeping like would like
sure reports know whether they need
headers or not but why does external
code need to say hey do you need a
header in that case do your header
maybe we better just say do your header
and some reports would be I'm good
right they don't need a header they just
return
that works
why does the external code need to know
how many lines there are in the body of
the report just do your body
I mean I'm making these functions up
so I can make them up however I like so
these are both right
some people when they see that one they
go
why does the calling code need to know
there is a header then there's the body
then there's a footer why don't we just
have do report and I'm not going to
argue that's what happens when you start
putting missing abstractions in
as the code gets simpler and you can
understand it then you can say things
like
I got business logic in the wrong place
the logic that says a report starts with
a header then there's a body then
there's a footer that's report talk that
belongs inside report why does some code
that's not in report knowing that
and your instructions get better
it's very common to find especially an
older code but it happens in newer code
too classes that are very similar but
only similar right and going through and
bringing inheritance into play can make
a real difference here now this doesn't
have to mean polymorphism and
indirection and virtual functions this
can be your common or garden
implementation inheritance you're
already using what John lamb calls
editor inheritance copy paste
the problem with editor inheritance is
you don't necessarily edit the same for
the history of time right
so imagine that you have like an old
system that sent faxes and there's a
class called facts
and roughly 20 years ago somebody also
wanted this thing to be able to send
emails so they made a class called email
using editor inheritance they copied
fax.h and fax.cpp to email.h and
email.cpp and then went through
effectively with a crayon Crossing out
facts and writing an email and then they
made a few changes because faxes go to
phone numbers but emails go to addresses
maybe emails can be cc'd that kind of
thing made a few changes
and then over time
these two classes have been
living in parallel maybe there's not two
now maybe there's seven
right because maybe in addition to faxes
and emails you can also send texts and
whatsapps and whatever else
and it's starting to bother people when
you need to make a change that you need
to make that same change in seven places
so if you put all the commonality in a
base class
and then have each of the drive classes
just only override what's different for
them
maybe some of the times when you need to
make changes you only need to make it in
the one place in the base class instead
of the seven different places uh in
these what are now derived classes but
used to be independent just similar
classes
this can be a wonderful way to fix
mystery bucks
it can also be a way to get the business
very mad at you
and you need to know this is one of the
few times when you need to check with
the business
imagine that you can export as XML and
as Json
and you discover
the XML exports include the sales tax
and the Json reports do not
feels like a bug right you're going to
be a hero you're going to fix the bug
you're going to get a phone call
it's pretty common to hear oh yeah we we
had a new customer and they wanted it in
Json but they also wanted the sales tax
included so we just have the Json export
include the sales tax for them and the
old customers they didn't want the sales
tax they're still just using the XML
report
as common as dirt what appears to be a
simple format difference is actually a
business rule difference
the PDF reports have subtotals and the
and the HTML reports don't because
they're for different external or
internal customers
so when you find this similar stuff you
bring it together and you're going to
make everything consistent you need to
phone someone
or email someone or slack someone or
Discord someone or whatever and say is
it deliberate
that they're inconsistent in this way
and you may have to encode that and then
harking back to my naming talk you might
want to change the names right the
difference between these two exports is
not just that one's XML and one's Json
but that one has sales tax and one
doesn't you can put that in their names
they can be called like XML with sales
tax and Json without sales tax and now
people will understand this is a
deliberate choice
foreign
how many of you want to do this bit I
want to write a template anyone
the front row a few people in the front
right yeah I told right I'll write a
template everyone I was like no look
I'll do a lot of things but I'm not
going to become one of those template
writing people I get it
I get it I do and and that's fine there
are other things you could do if you've
got a bunch of very similar functions
you could find some Base Class of
whatever this thing works with
and have your function just take that so
I'll have to write it once and I'll call
derived functions and that's better than
having seven versions of my function
I'll have one that works with something
they have in common that can be the
right choice
I can find maybe not something they all
are but something they all have so think
about the STL which I know is a template
so maybe not a good example but they
work they don't work with containers
they work with iterators right and all
the containers have iterators so is
there something like that that you could
do instead of having your function take
a document it could take the text that's
in the document and work that way
or I could write a helper function and
all my similar functions could all call
the helper function
if those aren't wrong
if you are thinking of doing those
things go ahead but templates are often
cleaner let me choose the world's
simplest example of adding
of a function called add int that takes
two integers and returns an integer
then I have another function called add
colors I don't know quite what that
would mean but it takes two colors and
returns a color and add string returns a
string
there's no natural commonality
right you can't say these are all
Edibles or something and then call their
derived plus function that's just weird
okay and there's also the problem of the
return type
if I make this take something vague
and then I call it with two strings then
I have to cast whatever I get back
because I know it's really a string
because I called it with two strings
like this kind of getting gross
but if you make a template It Takes Two
T's and returns a t you're done
cleaner
so if you're really tying yourself in
knots and especially if you're tying
yourself in knots around return types
consider writing a template I swear it
does not hurt I have written templates
it didn't hurt it's sometimes very very
cool so you wouldn't really reach for it
I want to encourage you to think about
it
and I love this example
this comes from the book
guy wrote this
if we're on Windows and you want to know
whether the letter A was pressed or not
you call a global function called get
key State passing in the Single
Character a
you bitwise and that with 8 000 because
of course you do and uh if that's
non-zero then someone press the letter A
uh for Linux he wasn't prepared to even
write it down
and you will see this stuff
sprinkled throughout
user interface code
if you have a function
that's on average a couple dozen lines
long it'll probably be only once in each
function but there might be 10 different
functions in the same file that have
this check in them and of course you're
not just checking for whether or not the
letter A was pressed you have another
check for whether or not someone's
pressed control something or another and
all the different
platform specific things you might need
to check for
and the key to what I'm going to show
you as an abstraction is to understand
that I mispronounced the if
most of us pronounce this if as if we
are running on Windows
if we're on Windows
that's not what's being checked for it's
not a runtime check
if we are building four windows
and that changes everything
make a file actually make several files
called for example keypress.h
the windows version of keypress.h does
the getkey state thing
the Linux version of keypress.h does the
complicated thing but they both think
declaring this function called Key State
user code just calls Key State after
including keypress.h
your build system
make sure the right header gets included
because that's how those flags got set
right when you're building for Windows
you set the win32 flag when you're
building for Linux you set the Linux
flag
well why not when you're building for
Windows include the windows version of
keypress.h when you're building for
Linux include the Linux version
oh all of a sudden you can actually
support three platforms without trying
to deal with what is effectively a
switch statement in preprocessor
includes because you could just have
three files
and all of the window stuff is in one
file all of the Linux stuff is in one
file it's a beautiful example of
isolation your windows aware person
maintains the Windows File your Linux
aware person maintains a Linux file and
everybody else can ignore it they just
call in Key State then a miracle occurs
I don't know why it works but it works
it comes from realizing that the if is
not testing what we're running on but
what we're building for and we have
better ways of building for different
platforms than we used to have I love
this example as a way to eliminate
complexity entirely
there there is no complexity when you're
when you're done
once you understand that which
keypress.h got included is chosen by
your build system
now I mentioned the idea of a report
type and it's it's common as dirt
you have an account type a report type a
document type a whatever it's not wrong
classes have a type member variable all
the time and it lets you every once in a
while do special things for special
kinds of accounts or special kinds of
reports
where it starts to hurt is as everything
grows
and go from having two types to having
20 types to having 200 types
and you go from having mostly
commonality with a little bit of special
handling to pretty much all special
handling and that's when the type
approach is probably not helping you
anymore
a switch statement that fits on a screen
is useful better than a bunch of ips a
switch statement that is 5000 lines long
not so much
and especially when you find functions
where there is no commonality
but the entire thing is just a switch
statement
this was the dream if you will
I'm going to print the header of this
report and this would be no different if
it was a member function of report okay
I'm going to have a bunch of common
stuff 1500 lines of commonality the top
50 100 lines of commonality at the
bottom and then this one little switch
for just this special stuff to know the
basic header the customer header the big
customer header this is using the same
enume that I invented half an hour ago
for the defines
fine
that's like 10 lines
there's 50 lines above it 50 lines below
it there's just a little diversion no
big deal
when there's three report types
when there's 200 report types things get
kind of yuckier
and especially when there's 200 report
types
and most of them do the same things as
each other
this is a very very simplified version
of stuff I saw in real life
I have a function called footer needed
which you saw being used in the nested
fours and Wilds all it is is a switch
there's nothing in there besides the
switch and we have these different case
statements but all it can do is return
true or false so if there are 200 report
types and there often are
this means case
100 case statements in a row return true
and then case something else in another
100 or so return uh case statements in a
row and then return false
that's really nasty where do you put
them like when I have to add a new one
what order do I add them in are they
alphabetical or the numerical according
to the old numerical defines we aren't
using anymore like and maybe someone
already added it that's fun uh and
you'll notice we have this assert false
now down at the bottom which is
something that developers put in
to protect themselves because there's
food are needed there's header needed
there's 12 20 different functions you
have to remember to add cases to all of
them so you have the assert so that if
you forget it'll catch it for you and I
know there are now compiler settings to
do that for you but this sample code
comes from before that time
and this is hard to maintain it's also
almost impossible to read
like if someone says I'm not getting a
footer on the reports for
such a customer
and you go and you look and you see that
it's a big customer report answering a
simple question like are we supposed to
have a footer on the big customer report
can be reasonably difficult to do
and I faced this with a real customer
they had a simple 21 step procedure for
adding a new report
and it was simple because I wrote it up
for them what they had before was you
phoned someone and they walked you
through it for several hours so it was a
huge Improvement that I wrote up their
21 step procedure but we obviously
needed to make it simpler than that
and so we had this class report already
and all I did was make the
individual specific reports derive from
report and added little tiny overrides
like here footer needed return false
that's easy to read if you want to know
whether the the Europe basic report
includes Footers or not pretty easy to
go and read this function and say that
looks like a no
much easier than the old switch approach
and uh two ways you can come about this
one is if it's always true if all
reports have Footers except for the
three weirdos
then you can have a implementation in
the base class that returns true and
only override it for the three weirdos
which will make it really obvious for
people who are trying to answer the
question
or if you're worried you'll forget you
can make it pure virtual in the base
class and then the compiler will tell
you that you forgot to implement the
pure virtual function in the drive class
either way much simpler than putting
assert falses in the defaults of
switches
and I have to tell you I did that in
real life and it worked beautifully and
it took the effort to add new reports
down
by by much less than half it was much
much quicker afterwards and it made a
difference because they charged
customers for adding reports so let them
either make more profit or charge less
depending how you want to look at it
sometimes when I insist on good names
for things the truth comes out that the
reason something doesn't have a good
name
is because it's not really a good sized
abstraction
functions that are called update and
process and do it in classes that are
called stuff and data and information
oh you all act like you never wrote one
but I know you did
the reason you can't name them is
they're the wrong size and you should
maybe split it up
what does it keep track of what does it
do
this is all the way back to like CRC
cards from 40 years ago but
if it's doing more than one thing it
probably is more than one thing
how are you gonna break it up
white space is again your friend
sometimes there's comments but there
doesn't have to be
so here's all our private member
variables and here's a blank line and
then there's some more private member
variables why that is a note from the
past maybe it's only from yesterday but
it's a note from the past right
two thingies
here's all our public member functions
oh sure look your special ones your
Constructors your destructors that are
then a blank line then the good stuff I
get that but why is your good stuff
broken into two pieces
because there's two pieces right I'm
boring your watch to tell you what time
it is but you know what okay I'm showing
you how to read watches this is how it's
done
same with the gaps between the blocks of
the code when you implement those
functions
it's telling you about the grouping all
you need to do is read it
but people say to me
why why are you breaking up my beautiful
information
it's it's so easy
that's that's why I'm breaking it up
because it's so easy
okay because
you just start using stuff like hey look
the font is right there I'm going to use
the font that's going to be helpful and
you're taking
a chance that you're breaking something
else
we already say we don't want Global
mutable State why it's so easy if all
our variables were globals how easy life
would be no because we would break stuff
when you separate things you have a
better design when you have
encapsulation you have a better design
and when you're explicit about what's
going across boundaries and you minimize
what goes across boundaries you have a
better design
so imagine I have a class that
represents an employee
and it's full of stuff about that person
as a human being
their name their birth date where they
live
it's stuff about their business
relationship with you your employee
their salary how many hours they've
worked this year how much vacation
they've used and then some stuff about
your and their shared relationship with
the government
how many taxes you've already taken off
and sent to the government on their
behalf that kind of thing these are
three like separate things
if you have code that sends people
birthday cards I have vendors who send
me birthday cards I find really creepy I
didn't give them my birthday so they
could send me cards but they do but if
you're going to send your employees
birthday cards that's different from
writing up their tax paperwork at the
end of the year right
so you say I'm going to split my
employee class into these three
functions that's great but then or into
these three subclasses but then where do
I keep the functions
so chances are you're going to make a
class called personal employee personal
information employee will have a member
variable Pi which is their personal
information and another one with their
tax stuff another one with their salary
stuff
and I need to write your tax slip at the
end of the year
so that's a function in employee right
now
will I move it into one of these
aggregated classes well probably not
because there's outside code calling it
but I might just delegate right the the
function sitting in employee might do
nothing but call the tax slips uh
prepare method
but is it the tax slips prepare method
or is it the personal information method
like you have to make a decision
most of the time it can be as simple as
numerically I use seven things from this
new
smaller class and none from the others
well I guess it's a member function of
that
where it's kind of balanced like your
tax slip has your name and address on it
which is your personal information yeah
but this is about your taxes right so it
goes in the taxes class
making the information that you're
passing around obvious
alerts you when you're taking a
dependency that maybe you should not be
taking
that's what's best about a good
splitting up why do I need my home
address to print my tax slip well that's
easy in Canada we're supposed to print
the home address on the tax slip okay
but maybe in some other countries you
don't do that so you're like why are you
passing personal information in
I have to rearrange the inside of the
class it may be enough to rearrange
those Getters and Setters that I said
you shouldn't have run off to write
imagine a huge class with all these
getters
it's got something to do with uh
displaying text on a screen probably
right we've got some X Y coordinates
foreground and background color actual
text
and we have dozens of gets dozens of
sets and then presumably a whole pile of
like business logic as well
if you just leave the member variables
alone but change these gets
so that they return little abstractions
like location and appearance
it's much more obvious that you need to
call them kind of in clumps probably
everyone was calling get X immediately
then called get why why not make a
single call to location and get the X
and Y
but only the X and Y if you want to know
the colors you need to make another call
makes it more obvious which things are
using what out of this big interface
and this is about
the constant change
if I need another parameter where I used
to call get X and get y
I just let well I'll just call get text
now without really thinking
now I have to think about it why do I
need more information should I change
location should there be more stuff in
location that I could call
gives you better design
because when we're in a hurry we just
make it work
the idea behind abstraction is to
protect you from accidental dependencies
and Rippling changes and that's why
you're putting these in place
I see that I very carefully arranged for
power and then didn't actually you know
plug it into my laptop
there you go
foreign
I know what you need to do
did you see it it said call to action
for a minute uh and I will try to wake
it up for the sake of the recording oh
it's really unhappy now
um
what I want you to do is to listen to
the code when it's telling you that
there are abstractions that are missing
okay whether you wrote it or whether
you're just reading it it is telling you
there's missing abstractions and when
you provide those missing abstractions
you're going to make the code better for
you and for future people you don't need
to understand sales tax nuclear reactors
chemical refineries rental car business
you just need to look for those
load-bearing white spaces those names
that are so similar for what's clumped
together and what's separate
and and then just listen to the code now
don't be super mechanical about it you
do bring judgment to this it is still
important to be a designer and be able
to put things together correctly but
don't be overwhelmed by it
uh just automatically and say well I
couldn't possibly because I could never
design this system from scratch that's
fine you don't have to design the system
from scratch you just have to listen to
what the code is telling you
and most importantly as you write stuff
you could leave some notes for the
future some blank lines some comments
but you could also just take that note
right now and work on it and make the
code better right now and that would be
uh even better
once you know to see them those blank
lines those gaps they are absolutely
screaming at you and all you got to do
is listen and I encourage you to do just
that and look through your code for
abstraction patterns thank you